veinticuatro horas después de su
encarnizado discurso el fiscal económico
dio a conocer las penas que solicita
para el ex presidente francés nicolas
sarkozy su abogado tiene jackson y el
juez jubilado y ha sido en este caso
conocido como de las escuchas o paul
mismo finalmente para el expediente que
se exponía diez años de cárcel ha pedido
solamente cuatro años de cárcel dos con
obligación de pena mismo castigo para su
abogado y para el juez un jubilado pero
además para terriers o pide cinco años
de prohibición del ejercicio profesional
en general ministerio público considera
que nicolas sarkozy y su abogado eran
conscientes de que estaban realizando un
delito de los que se le acusa que son de
corrupción activa y de tráfico de
influencias según la transcripción de
las conversaciones que pudimos escuchar
durante este proceso ambos intentaron
efectivamente conseguir información del
juez así ver y también que él los
ayudara en un proceso de que estaba
siendo investigado nicolas sarkozy a
cambio de un cargo en el principado
según el ministerio público
y nicolas sarkozy se arrepintió eso no
quita que haya querido cometer estos
delitos y lo peor de todo es que siendo
presidente habiendo sido un mandatario
con su actuar le hizo un gran daño a los
valores republicanos